Nát hoa tại tượng đại chủ tịch của chiming, thủ tưởng chính phủ phạm chính các đoàn công tác thì cận miên mình
tưởng nhớ chủ tịch của chiming vì lãnh tủ vì đại người cũng dân tộc.
Giây nhân bán hoa thế giới, người đặt nên mắng đầu tiên cho quan hệ hiểu miệ giữa nhân dân hai nước Việt Nam liên số này là liên bằng nha.
Người an luôn dưới dinh phát vì tình cảm thủy chung với đất nước.
Những dân nha, xây dựng quan hệ Việt Nam liên bằng nha ngay kăng đi vào chiều sâu thực chất bên chặt, kiệu quả.
Tượng đại hồ chiming tại mắt cơ vâ không chỉ là công chiên nghệ thuật mà còn là nước ở cưỡ tưởng miệm của cộng đồng người Việt tạnh nha.
Đặc biệt trong các viếp lễ kiến điểm quan trọng, đây cũng là diểm đến tủ hô khách tốt tế,
có phần thách chặt hơn nữa mới quan hệ hiểu miệ giữa Việt Nam và liên bằng nha.
Sáng cùng ngay, tủ tưởng chính phủ phạm miệ giĩnh và đoàn công tác đã tới đặt hoa tại tượng đại lịch xí vô dành ở buồn alai săng đơ.
Bên cảnh bức tưởng phía tây của định Cran, bây tỏng ngữ mộ trên trọng liên xí vô dành của hồn của liên xô đã hi sinh trong chiến tranh về quốc vỷ đại của liên xô trước đây.
Và nay là liên bằng nha từ những năm miệng chính trọng bộn mốt, một miệng chính trọng bộ lâm.
Tượng đại làm một trong những công chiên tưởng miệm thiêu liên của nước nước nha.
Được khánh thành vào ngày mong tám tháng năm năm, một miệng chính trọng xóa bài.
Tương năm mong yên chính trọng chiên bài, theo xác lại của tổng thống nha, như tức lỗi gác của Trung Duan Cran, được tổ chức hàng giờ tại đây.
Hãy cho vị chính khu chức làng liên, như lễ này trở thành vừa tượng trang nghiên, tụi hút đông đạo dù khách và người dân đến tượng miệng.